only when the last tree has been cut
down
the last fish been caught
and the last stream poisoned
will we realize we cannot eat money
there are two wolves fighting inside all
of us
the first one is evil
the second one is good
which wolf will win
the one you feed
when you were born you cried and the
world rejoiced
live your life so that when you die
the world cries
and you rejoice
it is better to have less thunder in the
mouth
and more lightning in the hand
[Music]
listen
or your tongue will make you deaf
seek wisdom
not knowledge
knowledge is of the past
wisdom is of the future
the weakness of the enemy makes our
strength
[Music]
do not judge your neighbor until you
walk two moons in his moccasins
they are not dead who live in the hearts
they leave behind
there is nothing as eloquent as a
rattlesnake's tail
[Music]
it is less of a problem to be poor
than to be dishonest
[Music]
a brave man dies but once
a coward many times
[Music]
make my enemy brave and strong
so that if defeated
i will not be ashamed
the bird who has eaten cannot fly with
the bird that is hungry
cherish youth
but trust old age
wisdom comes only when you stop looking
for it and start living the life the
creator intended for you
not every sweet root gives birth to
sweet grass
[Music]
take only what you need
and leave the land as you found it
it is no longer good enough to cry peace
we must act peace
live peace
and live in peace
when a man moves away from nature
his heart becomes hard
beware of the man who does not talk
and the dog that does not bark
[Music]
our pleasures are shallow
our sorrows are deep
it does not require many words to speak
the truth
don't let yesterday
use up too much of today
if a man is as wise as a serpent
he can afford to be as harmless as a
dove
[Music]
poverty is a noose that strangles
humility
and breeds disrespect for god and man
[Music]
remember that your children are not your
own but are lent to you by the creator
walk lightly in the spring
mother earth is pregnant
ask questions from your heart
and you will be answered from the heart
[Music]
there is no death
only a change of worlds
what is life
it is a flash of firefly in the night
it is a breath of a buffalo in the
wintertime
it is as the little shadow that runs
across the grass
and loses itself
in the sunset
which quote did you like the most share
your opinion in the comments one day you
will regret that you did not hear these
quotes earlier do not lose the
opportunity watch our next video